écouter de la musique classique dès le
plus jeune âge pour éveiller ses sens
violent où il y avait aussi
alors franchement ça devient le bras
long il avait rappelé hier le plus grand
du genre mais qui ressemble lever 11 l
amazone spécialisé en pédagogie musicale
ce voyage initiatique est avant tout une
aventure collective et sensorielle il ya
une histoire qui est tissée autour de
toutes les activités
on va écouter certainement saut de louis
la cinquième symphonie mais aussi des
moins connus comme la colère pour un sou
perdu et puis on va faire des activités
toujours avec ça on sait composer un
orange pour sa 6éme sans fond
ici à la musique dans ce qu'elle a de
plus beau le partage au fil des
symphonies de beethoven les enfants
laissent libre cours à leur imagination
et re créer leur propre univers gai
norduyn l'appui
bonjour l'orage
c'est une expérimentation une découverte
une sensibilisation à la musique ce que
ça peut représenter la musique l'art de
la nuit au delà des notes découvrir la
vie et l'oeuvre du célèbre compositeur
allemand qui fête ses 250 ans cette
année c'est apprendre et s'enrichir de
notre foisonnante histoire européenne